[Musique]
vous le savez encore la semaine dernière
avec notre reportage sur les
stérilisations dans consentis on a une
sensibilité particulière à l'émission
pour les enjeux qui touchent les
autochtones en cette première journée
nationale de la vérité de la
réconciliation on vous a préparé un
montage d'extraits de nos reportages d
année dernière pour se souvenir du
courage de ceux et celles qui se sont
confiés à nous
et une fois ils ont dit avait pas de
voir ta fille oubliera avait pas de moi
sa fille et ses 146 a fait le point je
voyais les autochtones en vie une chaîne
fox thème apparentés chapeau qui était
dans ma parole ce qui me frappe chez ces
monuments
non mais la voile et à nous envoyer
notre sens c'est ça qu'on dit c'est à
peu près ça c'est penser
[Musique]
voilà première fois vers la pointe
maroni dans la loge les meubles à kedar
namur
tout de suite ça mais descend durable
j'ai dans mon bain
[Musique]
j'ai parlé comme pro-syriens te tape le
là qu'est ce que je vais au passage
il m'a cru et sinon
battus et nuls appel au calme
damen à moi
j'ai d'épargné d'abord yop à sanaa mais
j'ai quand même de ces cas là le sait
qu'à ne pas savoir qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
été aussi bilan lamia maison pc mois que
là
c'est moi que
ma fête
[Musique]
une maquette d'un casque à cb
j'aimerais dans la contrée un jour de
police et
j'aimerais tellement rencontrer plus
pouvoir le regarder en face pigments
décide s'il me reconnus s'ils se
souvient de moi s'il sait que ça fait
plusieurs années que baptisé ma vie
puis je sais je suis pas la seule
[Musique]
à force de répéter de marsan sont
devenus les indiens
dans leur car l'islam vive la sauge pied
par terre comme que du touquet
comédie m'offrait un film d'eau sur les
chamans
[Musique]
à tous ceux qui ont témoigné on veut
vous dire me gouache je ne commettais na
tomique merci nous avoir fait confiance
[Musique]